let's bring in ohio republican
congressman jim jordan whose appointment
to the committee was rejected by house
speaker
nancy pelosi congressman jordan thanks
for being here good to be with you brett
did you see the hearing today i got to
watch part of it but actually i was in
another
committee another select committee one
that speaker pelosi's allowed me to be
on
the coronavirus select committee so i
got to watch bits and pieces but i was
actually
in a committee hearing asking questions
and making statements saw the review
there by chad obviously emotional
powerful testimony your thoughts about
that
no it was a terrible day and the people
who did wrong need to be held
accountable
and brett that's exactly what's
happening the real question is and i've
said this many times is
why weren't those guys who testified
today and all the other capitol hill
police who protect us and protect
capitol hill
why weren't they given more help why
wasn't more help there that day and the
only person who can answer that question
is the speaker of the united states
house of representatives and i think she
thought we were going to keep raising
that question and that's why she didn't
put me on because remember brad
there was a story in politico last
wednesday morning which means the
speaker's office talked to the press the
day before
that said the headline said democrats
accept leader mccarthy's selections and
then something changed and i think it's
the fact that i raised that issue
last tuesday that fundamental question
is the one that needs to be answered and
the fact that we're going to continue to
raise that
i think is the reason we're not on the
committee how would you have asked that
today
well today i think the folks today was
on why we didn't have more people there
so i asked these guys did you need
one of the officers i think part i did
see part of this where he said we
weren't prepared
for what was going to happen why weren't
you why wasn't the information given to
you
there have been news reports that said
speaker pelosi
vetoed vetoed bringing the national
guard here and then the day of the
attack there's been news reports that
said she hesitated
on calling up the national guard why why
not my
my hunch is brett my hunch is because
what happened all last summer
last summer we saw speaker pelosi and
the democrats
say that we should defund the police we
saw speaker pelosi and the democrats say
that
riders and looters who attacked police
destroyed small business and hurt
innocent civilians they actually raised
money to bail them out of jail so when
that's the background
it's kind of tough to say we're for
defunding the police but oh by the way
we want more police here to protect us
on january 6. here's congressman
jeffries
addressing what you're talking about
there and speaker pelosi
well the fact that kevin mccarthy
continues to blame
speaker pelosi it's just such a sick
and cynical act of
diversion and distraction those rioters
those protesters
were there in part to assassinate nancy
pelosi
what does kevin mccarthy not get about
that
irresponsible no one's blaming anyone
for what happened that day except the
people who did wrong
those are the people to blame and guess
what they're being prosecuted
just like our system is supposed to work
we're just asking a fundamental question
a fundamental question if there are news
reports that said that
that speaker pelosi vetoed having the
national guard there that the sergeant
of arms said that the speaker's office
told him they were concerned about the
optics that's a real question that's a
fundamental question
why wasn't there a proper security
posture on january 6
and what have we done to correct that
and so it make sure it doesn't happen
in the future i think those are
fundamental questions it's not about
blame the blame resides with the people
who did wrong
they should be prosecuted and they are
being oh there was
a little bit of talk about blame today
officer gannell talking about
the former president stirring up that
crowd take a listen to this
all of them were telling us trump sent
us nobody else there was nobody else it
was not antifa it was not black live
matters
it was not the fbi it was his supporter
that he sent him over to the capitol
that day and he could have done a lot of
things
one of them was to tell them to stop
all those officers said there's not
politics involved in this they're
testifying of what they believe
happened that day and their reaction to
it what's your thought about what he
just said there
well the i believe capitol hill police
and the great work they do there's not
politics there but there's certainly
politics with this committee
we know this committee is out to get the
former president the the former
president who said that day peacefully
and patriotically make your voices heard
i mean we saw the president's entire
speech
that's been that's been seen and viewed
i don't know how many times we've had
all kinds of commentaries alan
dershowitz has talked about it
so there was the president didn't incite
anything the people who did wrong
they need to be held accountable they're
going to be held they're being held
accountable as we speak
so this committee is obviously going to
go down a number of different roads uh
about who knew what when who was talking
to coordinators of the protest
did you talk to the former president
that day i've talked to the former
president umpteen times thousands
i mean i may not i mean on january
countless times i talk to the president
i never talk about what we talk about so
i just don't think that's appropriate
just like i don't talk about what
happens in republican conferences
so i've talked to the president numerous
times uh i continue to talk to the
president
on january 6 congressman yes i mean i've
talked to the president
i've talked to the president so many i
can't remember all the days i've talked
to him but i've certainly talked to the
president yeah
and and on that day was
can you share any of the insight of what
he was thinking about that day
uh brett the people we need to come
testify are the people who can testify
to
the fundamental questions why didn't the
united states capital the people's house
have an appropriate
security posture on that day and what
have we done those are the people we
need to hear from
those that's information and testimony
we need to get
that's what we should focus on but i
don't think that benny thompson the
chairman of this committee said
everything's on the table until we raise
this issue about the speaker's office is
the one who knows
what what the security posture and why
it was the way it was
once we raised that question said well
everything's on the table except that
question
again that's why i think we were kicked
off the committee which i think
underscores
how political this thing actually is and
i would argue this
the main reason democrats want to keep
talking about january 6
because what the heck else are they
going to talk about brett they're going
to talk about the 12 murders in chicago
last week they're going to talk about
the price of goods and services up for
everything
they're going to talk about the fact
that our border i mean we had a record
number of illegal crosses in march until
april and then we had a record number in
april until may we had a record number
in may
until june that is a bad trend they
can't talk about any of that stuff
so they're going to focus on doing what
they always do attack the former
president all things that we're covering
extensively here but finally you heard
these officers a number of them said
that they were dismayed
by lawmakers who seem to in their words
be downplaying
january 6 or uh the magnitude
of it i'm not accusing you congressman
but is there a message for lawmakers who
may have done that
no i think the message is i've never
downplayed january 6 uh what we've done
what i've done and what republicans have
done
is we've been consistent we said what
happened last summer
in these in so many of our urban areas
to police officers to small business
owners and to our fellow citizens was as
wrong as wrong could be
and we said what happened on january 6
was as wrong as wrong could be
we've been consistent the people who
haven't are the democrats and that's why
they continue to focus on this because
they can't talk about the fact that they
defunded the police and all the things
they said when they raised money
to bail out rioters and looters from
jail they can't talk about those things
so they're going to focus on this and
attacking
the former president congressman jordan
we appreciate your time
thank you brad take care hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else